good morning everyone good morning
Millennials happy Thursday
what a happy Thursday Thursday filled
with pollen and allergies for me second
at the back half of the week is lit like
it's so spectacular
it's almost better than the weekend
because we have something to look
forward to where's the weekend the pit
there's this constant sense of dread and
like it's just a funny cuz like compared
to the front half a week like this
couldn't be Monday do you know what I
mean yeah but it's not it's Thursday and
then tomorrow is Friday and today is the
first day of my shows at Caroline's I
will see all of you at 7 o'clock and or
9:30 it's gonna be extremely late and
they have the best chicken burgers at
Caroline's so I'm really excited how are
you feeling in preperation person hor
you prepared you need to work try out
some material like Amy Schumer
interpreting an up-and-coming comedy
Carol yeah one of our stories are no but
okay what's crazy about this basically
if you don't know the story Englishmen
were like ransacked a random night at
Caroline's which is a comment yeah that
I'm owed to nights ago not last night
the night before well duh
two nights ago and cuz she wanted to try
out some new material I'm like a fresh
audience why don't you try out her SNL
monologue so apparently she like a
bombarded her way upstage and like that
was a story but like just imagine if she
like wanted to try it out on Thursday
like she would have it's very possible
like it could have happened that she
would have just come in like realize it
was like a private thing and like she's
like hey it's Amy Schumer like can I get
on stage and it would have sat I really
buy and like let her do it and just like
kept letting her do she only took ten
minutes but she could have had in the
whole hour you know if you're seeing
this and you still need more practice
I'm free Thursday and Friday night and
she's a big fan of your work she loves I
feel pain I know that you made it up
after me and I see and her audience
would also like your jokes yeah okay
what would come through be so crazy
it would be crazy it's just like imagine
if I have decided to do the shows May
8th
you know what I mean it's too crazy to
think about it's too crazy to think
about but anyways also you announced
your one show so if you weren't able to
get tickets to the toast Nashville don't
cry we're doing the girl with no jobs
show in Nashville I'm thinking about
maybe you having a special guest then I
also like to I want to give the
attention to someone else like I'm
really struggling but sometimes it's fun
and it takes like the the pressure off
of you yeah second so there are still
tickets left
I'm really
excited and I hope everyone can make it
it's June 5th I'm happy happy to change
our flight it's like we need to go are
you gonna change your fight I don't know
I really don't want to time was perfect
and I could still do the toasts and I
don't want to get charged okay we should
just leave it to fate and chance really
and then we'll talk about it later okay
if anyone works for Delta be coaching
him but Jackie and I are here to deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast and it's a day
late and a dollar short but we're doing
dear toasters anyway we don't want to
rush through it yesterday with Vinnie
Guadagnino it's not even a dollar short
because they actually have four stories
for one extra and we're gonna be
recapping Mahoney and I haven't much
Riverdale yet anybody spoils him in the
comments I will finish you know my dm's
last night were a minefield I couldn't
go on Facebook I couldn't go on
Instagram like I was worried the
toasters Group was gonna spoil it for me
submit to texting me that she's crying
like Oh Ronnie tells me but something
like crazy crazy happy I think I know I
don't want to know what you think I'm
gonna watch it the minute I go home
because it wasn't on the CW app last
night and I just can't in a shunt talk
about it sweetie and enchant two girls
we're official we're official two girls
in Philly dedicated their graduation
caps to us in Maire before us with I
can't and chant graduation caps and I
truly can't my parents in ahsha when I
saw it I couldn't and I shouldn't and I
wouldn't should they forgot the went but
whatever wound is optional like you can
opt in for the wine
but you must can to me mush em do you
guys also I think we as a community need
to come together and really just uplift
one of our sisters who's down jackie is
feeling really like just like upset
because she posted something on
Instagram that got no likes no I didn't
post it like it's the toast but on my
behalf I would say because we spoke
about Allen Gregory on the show
yesterday and it wasn't just like a
one-off comment that I I wanted you guys
to take it to heart
clearly literally none of you have
watched shoot because it was our worst
performing post on the toes Instagram
account ever which told me everything I
needed to know which is that you guys
need to watch Allen Gregory just like
you needed to watch shits Creek just
like you needed to watch Riverdale have
we ever recommended something like that
wasn't premium no recommendable we never
have and I know Jonah Hill is somewhere
watching this smiling well I think it
- anything from our morning toasters
group which like I mentioned is
extremely lit it's that Jonah Hill
actually does open his DMS so because
this girl like who's like really cute
and pretty like da I'm Tim and he like
totally responded I think they ended up
like going out or something really I
hope so whatever like I'm gonna damn it
Jacob have you seen Alan Gregory we have
heard of it and you're not from us he's
heard of it I've heard of it your
homework assignment for this weekend
watch Allen Gregory I'm sure it's on
Amazon because everything's on em yeah
odd you didn't like old movies iTunes
yes okay here's your to-do list for this
weekend buy tickets to my show
watch Allen Gregory follow tiffany
thornton on instagram follow me on
instagram follow Jackie on instagram
follow club with no job pumping no job
boy with no job Marga Frey Olivia's
right body by snitch huh not the one on
trace at Morton coast great we got it
schedule set class session like a list
for you and we'll put it on our
Instagram just so you don't forget okay
just a little to-do list yeah okay
without further ado the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast first up in sad breakup
news ariana grande and Mac Miller have
split okay
like I'm sad for her because she's
probably sad right now but like she
could do so much better and I know
people like really ship them and like
because like her first song was with him
and like I I get it and like I'm not
into it like I think he's ugly I don't
ship them but I ship her happiness me
too so whatever it's gonna take to make
that little girl happy we got to do it
if it's not Mac Miller scram if it is
Mac Miller stay whatever she needs I'm
here for this is so tough because like
there's no one better that she can't
date up like she is up you know name
date out who she's the biggest pop star
in the world and she's gorgeous
okay she could date John Cena to shade
you win there's such different sizes
it's like two people from different
planets
you know dead-ass ariana grande probably
equals the weight of John Cena's thigh
one thigh 1 thigh 80 pounds yeah roughly
who else would you put her with a blood
debt like seriously like she's also
really young no storage we're not that
young girl yes we are what about like a
married guy like Scott Eastwood good
enough for her I
don't see it I see it visually see it
but I could see them together I just
don't see them like connecting I don't
see the chemistry gene but let's think
of other people on the music yes music
industry like me like a really high
profile like manager honestly what about
like I feel like these girls just
recycle man there's only three men in
Hollywood apparently the weekend I feel
like I could see them hooking up I could
see it too
but like I don't find him attractive no
but like I think he's attractive and
he's like so talented and there's like
and there's obviously something about
him that like these girls who could have
anyone in the world that's like fall at
his feet
yes and I I hope Arianna like I don't
know I could see her kind of like
falling for him I don't know I feel like
she falls hard today she loves hard yeah
like Big Sean I think that was a big
blow and like now he's still with that
girl but he'll always think her and Big
Sean are together forever I think that
they were perfect for each other
yeah but maybe it's just the timing and
also like I just think ariana grande's
like the top they're like the musical
genius of our generation she is the song
piano but will never not make me late
and you know who agrees with us and
that's the only endorsement that you
need David Foster
does he love our Elmo loves her really I
think she's like the Celine Dion of our
generation that's some interesting in
you know else really respects her is
Katy Perry on American Idol some girl
came and like auditioned with an
American Idol on that and she was like
honestly like singing and Ariana
Grande's song is really impressive
because she's literally the most
talented vocalist like including herself
you know okay yeah like she's literally
so good she said and the genesis of her
career is just beyond comprehension cuz
like all those kids from Disney had huge
careers but like Nickelodeon was like I
was like a step below mmm and no one
from Nickelodeon like really blew up
like ariana grande and it hadn't lasted
like amanda Bynes blew up it was a movie
star but like she couldn't last I mean
the king of the people now who are like
around from Nickelodeon it's like
Victoria Justice who has not touched a
script since literally 1992 Kenan
Thompson is true but like Josh Peck he's
an influence early and he's really good
at it like he's know alright a grande
know and they ran across Grove don't net
stop
donde esta miranda cosgrove we need to
hear from her
I totally in regard
to everything also ariana grande like
maybe in another world would be really
cute with Shawn Mendes okay I was gonna
say that too but he's taken it's like
well we have to be realistic also need
to say yesterday he gave a quote to
someone that they're just friends which
I also had fallen down a rabbit hole of
like Shawn Mendes hailey Baldwin
conspiracy theories and apparently he
told fans in like a Toronto Airport a
few days before like no matter what you
see Haley and I are not dating so like
even if we should like and I guess see
when they went to the MEK out together I
guess that doesn't automatically mean
that they're dating even though it does
know because they both wore Ralph Lauren
so they were like the Ralph Lauren duo
and they're also the prom king and queen
I'm really hungry
like like honestly I feel you can hear
my stomach rumbling in the microphone
there's pirates booty yes oh it's
election if you will
oh thank you Jacob okay sorry I'm like I
really like I'm not feeling good like
[ __ ] and I'm a big show tonight I can't
yeah you need to keep your spirits up
okay
sorry what were you need a little bit it
might help you with your spare no it's
called Burnham gun Colbert was so crazy
nasty yet you drink it all the time this
one's good I'm okay I'm okay help is on
the way dear we are saying Chad Mendes
and Haley Baldwin are not real I don't
know like their speculation as to as to
why well you know I get deep in the
blinds and what they said was like Haley
Baldwin like isn't an automatic
invitation to the mecca oh yeah just one
more time for the she's in the Mac look
you would think she is because of the
crew that she hangs with but she's not
automatically like considered because
she's for the Met Gala but I guess what
I didn't realize is like she's really
she partial height yeah she's not as
tall as that other girls she'll never be
a Victoria Secret Angel that's crazy
that just like your height something
that you can't control can just sky me
your whole career so I think like in
exchange for getting invited she was
like antibodies what do we got here
fruit snacks a goldfish I could have
[ __ ] heavily with goldfish fruit snacks
yeah okay okay I'll go with the goldfish
first fruit snacks are so underrated
just over here if you are there
discussing they have cobs and she
well I I'm just only I'm sorry to all
the podcast listeners who are about to
hear me crunching but like all right
yeah how does a taste they call to me
and crunch legs victory okay anyways
Ariana Grande is a single woman now and
I look forward to seeing what she does
next look my favorite part about like
following along with people's careers it
was like their success and stuff but
also who they did and like what they
choose to do with it because some people
like it so big that they only want to
date normal people like you know but
some people just you know reach print
stars by the way you know who we were
talking about it's a little weird like
Olivia culpo wasn't at the McCallum
mm-hmm I spoke to some insiders and this
is what they said and honestly I wasn't
shocked like she's too overexposed and
like really she's like a very successful
revolve girl and that does not make a
Met Gala invitee
okay so then gold and Barbie is there so
that's the difference between that's
what everyone was saying last night
golden Barbie was there because she's
much more fashioning and she's dated in
the celebrity world and that elevates
her a lot but and she's literally
amazing and she's friends with Kim like
totally she's literally amazing and she
looked at me and she deserves it she
deserves a bit like I think Olivia culpo
does too but I could I could see she's a
little too commercial no and she's
really like everywhere yeah and people
who go to the mckellar like rarely seen
you know what I mean you see that [ __ ]
all the time I guess and it's done a
reality show like she's everywhere
okay I don't know maybe next year I'm
sure and also it's like you said it's
good to have goals you can't just have
everything you know you should have a
minute chief
what's your goal um like I don't know I
I I can't think of one right now
okay what's your goal enough look
special oh no oh that's a good goal or
like if I'm being realistic like who is
special oh okay so like my goal would be
like GMA
so except like no Jenna may is I know
not you have a TV show
Today Show Today Show or like oh I was
gonna say the view but no I'm too scary
I'm Way too shy for the view I would
offer to go on the road and like
honestly was a huge opportunity but like
I would rather die no like I just
I can't even articulate I can't even
speak about the V let alone be on it
totally one hang out with Megan McCain
definitely think I would get along with
what we like for sure hind reverse I
think she would really like us AC and it
would not be down for to her she scares
the absolute [ __ ] out of me she even
scared Carl Lentz like that's when you
know she scares Meghan McCain and Meghan
McCain is a brave and takes her on on
the view great I followed the view on
Twitter like I think it's important to
be like a well-rounded individual and
they do clips and she's the meanest
woman alive what does she do she just
everything she doesn't scary I had a
meeting at ABC once and they have it's
like amazing cafeteria details pressure
to be the meanest woman why because like
that's a reputation it's an
ever-changing like your chair is not
guaranteed so you have to be the
something like Meghan McCain is the
conservative yeah and like so there has
to be the mean or there's always gonna
be someone meaner who's ready to take
your spot and there's only room for like
one wise old woman and that's what will
be over that's not true by her I feel
for her
well saying I'm at once at ABC and then
it's like amazing cafeteria with like a
fountain soda machine and joy bear has
have been I was having lunch there to
you and like it was a scariest lunch
then we weren't even close to each other
but it was scary I'm sure she thrives
off of that no one's come together okay
great next story are you ready for it
gird your loins trying to crunch luck so
what's up from you guys Claudia Devil
Wears Prada yes
Tristan Thompson opens up about daughter
true for the first time since her birth
and his cheating scandal Tristan
Thompson is talking publicly about his
newborn daughter true for the first time
since she arrived into the world the NBA
player 27 discussed his daughter nearly
one month after her birth while on the
road trippin podcasts Richard Jefferson
and Allie Clifton that was posted on
Tuesday a podcast damn podcast every
week says [ __ ] are the way puck is our
precision suspect they're like the new
medium for news it's like radio but
better yeah look specials we don't have
a car okay
the father of two revealed true who he
welcomed with Khloe Kardashian on April
12th is a healthy baby girl who was
quote doing good okay
I'm not gonna get into how that makes no
sense but what it's doing well and if
she's doing good and she's already doing
charity work oh the grammar police over
here
it was like it wouldn't bother me if I
just read it but he made me say those
incorrect words so I just need to crack
them Calgon it's like doing good sick
baby baby she was eating sleeping and
[ __ ] he said that's all they do
googled what do babies do the Keeping Up
with the Kardashians star and the
Cleveland Cavaliers player have kept
their daughters physical image under
wraps but he revealed a few details
about her looks while on the podcast she
has a full head of hair she has green
eyes Thomson revealed adding that true
was 21 inches long this is the first
girl Thompson female Thompson so it's
huge
yeah so he went on one of those websites
where they put celebrities pictures
together and make babies and he's a gift
full head hair green eyes I'm telling
you he has never met the baby I know
more about True Jackson VP Thompson than
he does I think with a girl you're just
so much more emotionally like with the
boy it's just like hey man you'll be
alright
stop crying he explained but with true
it's like true it's gonna be okay you
know we're right here daddy's here to
feed you it's me look yeah it's way
different but it's fun though it changes
you okay this is gonna sound really mean
boo sounds like the worst out of all
time well just be sound like the things
that we know about him it's not just
like generic like the BB hasn't stopped
crying like Oh original also like he
does have other children and I don't
know how much how present he is so
literally has the warts tasted mat it's
beyond she's also has like the worst
luck there was nothing wrong with Lamar
when she plucked him out of obscurity no
but I think she knew a lot about his
crack addiction and she but I think I
think he she tries to save people yeah
but he also he ruined Rob too look no
one says it but what's going on with Rob
is fully Khloe's fault
Fillion Lamar's fault and who brought
Lamar into the family Khloe but like
what she's just gonna like leave him
high and dry it's so it's so hard but
yeah let's just blame it all on Lamar
because that just makes it easier and no
thanks I don't breathing on the morrow
what else I don't know the reason I'm
overweight like just everything
everything is Lamar solved I totally
agree
okay any further thoughts on these to
the floor there I told you I'm really
done talk I know but because he gave his
first public interview I thought people
might give a [ __ ]
I thought they did on a podcast like
that's like good news her podcast
everywhere no it gives me hope for the
future
if anyone wants to come on our podcast
and talk about their newborn baby you're
welcome guys I've been a while I need
him loved he was hot he was so cute so
nice just a sweet guy cool dude regular
guy also Big Time magazine editor and
it's nice when a Big Time magazine
editor talks to young folk like us
totally know he was really cute and I
had met him like a long time ago doing
his podcast which was like lightyears
ahead of its time like it wasn't when
podcasts were a thing and he was so nice
back then and it's nice as he hasn't
changed yeah he's like he's into month
what's necessary to because I feel like
he's so like Internet and digital and he
was really able to parlay his like early
2000s reality show career into like
influence influence our society oh my
group which is all you can really ask
for in this world
okay so Instagram followers its
influence if you could have like
millions of followers on any platform
what would you wanna okay so like I want
to say Instagram but the truth is you to
know because that's the most lucrative
it's guaranteed money and they have the
easiest time getting followers on other
platforms that's true yeah I mean I
would have to go YouTube but youtube is
a lot of work and honestly like those
influencers on YouTube like work hard
it's their full-time jobs yeah like I
sometimes make a janky video in my
apartment and it takes me like half a
day you know it's crazy
imagine like doing edits and like it's
like magic when they throw their makeup
on the counter yeah how the [ __ ] know
they literally that's a vine [ __ ] did
they use vine to do that
I miss fine I don't what does fine -
coming out I thought there was a thing
no I don't mean me that was like April
Fool's it doesn't sound like a thing
okay and the nobody cares been doing a
lot better
I'm happy for you maybe maybe should
take a sip of champagne take the edge
off no I'm okay it's in sitting here for
three hours
okay Selena Gomez loved her Met Gala
dress but wanted to clap back at people
who criticized her tan okay so Selena
Gomez posted a video on Instagram to
clarify it as one of the people that
clapped back like we were clapping back
at her tan only her hair her makeup her
smile look please okay and now that
she's gonna try and like tell us it was
just a spray tan I feel better about
going in on her because like she that's
right now she's
not taking ownership of what went wrong
and I'm happy to provide some owners and
yet again not in tune with what's
necessary I mean she's never even heard
of what's being in tune with it I've
ever even used like she's never been to
Nantucket I've been using not in tune
what's necessary like so much more
recently because it's so personal to the
situation always
you're either in tune with what's
necessary or you're not there's two
types of people in this world I would
intend to Messina say we're in tune with
what's necessary I went to prestigious
dinner last night we were talking about
people and I was like they're just not
in tune with what's necessary and
everyone was like what like that's a
good job for my show
it didn't a good thing I'm like it's a
joke for my little Instagram joke it's a
joke for my podcast okay she posted a
video of her like running away in a
parking garage in her MEC I'll address
and the caption was me when I saw my
pictures from the met same girl so she's
trying to say that it was the spray tan
that made her look crazy nah the Selena
Gomez or the hung van gogh's a makeup
artist uh a source close to people
people's pretty legit they said in
person she honestly felt great but not
everything looks the same as it does in
person she was just clapping back at
people who were commenting on her hair
and her tan and wanted to make a joke
about it no it's funny but like when
you're in this fragile of a state that
she is like get off your phone and like
stop like making jokes I also like what
was she doing running through the
parking garage in her dress like that
videos gonna like I'm gonna be bacteria
like accumulating on the train of her
dress and I'm pretty sure her shoes are
off honestly like this is like whatever
the opposite of advertisement is of good
advertisement that's what this is her
coach like it yeah
really bad and it's like embarrassing
like just she should have let it slide
and she wore Tiffany jewelry and
Tiffany's I posted a picture and like it
was of her like horrible cause like it
must been really hard to find like a
good photo but here's the thing the
spray tan was bad but like spray tan is
to spray Canon I don't think the spray
tan was the worst part no the hair was I
think the hair and the makeup and I saw
an edit on Instagram someone edited her
makeup a little bit giving her a red lip
and taking away some of that nasty eye
shadow and she looked great which goes
to show this is all hung van Gogh's
fault who is her makeup artist who put
on a cryptic message on his Instagram
last night
you never know what battle someone
fighting and Novi was referring to him
or Selena I'm gonna go with him because
this was his [ __ ] yeah like she's a
gorgeous girl really no matter what
she's don't do all she has to do is
stand there yeah you made her look like
this you did this
yeah hide in her hair and the hair the
hair the hair is most unforgivable do we
know who did the hair I don't know but
that butter for you I guess clearly like
went into a cave yeah no they don't work
anymore
yeah oh my goodness I like I'm
struggling I feel sorry for her because
it's like this was out of her control
and now she's getting on the the flack
but I don't know I think you should
redirect our flack you guys yeah to the
makeup and hair artists
I'm just like straddling the line up
like really wanting to go in and make
like so much fun of her but then also
being like I feel like she could
literally be dead in the next year and
like I don't want to be the last person
to what made fun of her no so you don't
kick someone while they're down and you
don't do this kind of makeup on someone
mother now that's just right like
cardinal rule I completely agree about
that yeah okay next up Miranda Kerr and
Evans picot welcome a quote beautiful
Sun heart words cannot explain how happy
we are
I think they're so like shut day like
everything they do is so private look
please write your company went public
and you're so private yeah I just find
that interesting you know no I I don't
know they're like so weird maybe he's
like they're real and yeah that's why
they're just being normal they're just
weird to me because like their wedding
like weirded me out like it was
literally like someone's house but just
so sweet and so cute but she legit wore
like a night like a ball gown from like
the 20th century like in a house I mean
see if you can wear a dress like that
you have to be in like a ballroom yeah
it's I carry from Sex in the City like
it was bad it was at wedding she looks
like a long-sleeve renaissance dress and
it was like in like a kitchen you know
yeah well it was weird it is weird
they're a weird couple heart is a cute
name though har - he's named after her
Evans grandfather a source tells people
it's like a normal ish yeah for a
celebrity it's like heart Denton yeah
check chip don't say anything
literally like we mix episodes Barnes I
just found out that chick is not
actually related stuff like that's what
I found out right okay well we need to
wrap this show up because I need to go
home and write Riverdale so without
further ado congratulations Imran I've
been like was that a fit story no we
have one more story and
kind of switch it up and you don't know
what the story is I mean I don't mean
any of them so oh so excited so you
definitely don't know I'm looking
forward to the surprise queer ice Tom
Jackson and Abby Park get married for a
second time in private ceremony so and I
also wanted to take this time to talk
about queer eye because I don't think
we've talked about it cuz we both
watched it during the break and I don't
think we've haven't our love for it okay
let's talk about the wedding first
because I followed Tom on Instagram I
mean on Twitter like the second I saw
that episode and he has been a thirst
monster generally Netflix for a wedding
special he's like how great would it be
if the past five planned our wedding at
Netflix like he tweets that probably
went to dry yes fab 5 whatever you know
he was like illiterate every day like
responding to people like hey wouldn't
that be nifty if Netflix did a special
on the back 5 like it was just like I'm
going to a special on the Fast Five I
totally great it's obvious that he
didn't get it from what I'm hearing but
he did get written up and almost every
major minor magazine and like I don't
know I feel like he's like a little like
obsessed with the cameras and like he
was doing the wedding like for the
cameras and I don't know I just don't
feel like it's gonna last because like
there are no cameras I think it's gonna
last because their love was so beautiful
and pure on the show yeah the show
everyone was obsessed and it was a
little before our time like on Bravo so
I had never didn't know what the concept
was and I know it was like I thought it
was like a bunch of straight guys and
gay guys living in a house I didn't
really know what it was I never knew
what it was and I never even tried to -
it was like open arms and I went to it
with bed who was like it's just so not
his type of show and he probably ended
up loving it more than me and famous ACK
when we first saw it we were like the
branding looks like been made the best
call like the query logo looks like a
like a logo for like a glasses company
and Ben was like what are we watching
and then we watch the first episode
which was by the way I'm so glad they
used Tom for the first episode because
it was so heartwarming and like I just
have a lot to say about the show because
the dynamic between the past five Fab
Five sorry is interesting because
Jonathan Van Ness is like the breakout
star long haired groomer boy who's just
everything here everything in my eyes
the podcast have to have him - no I'm
working overtime I love him so much each
at first I think he came off like a
little extra and then I was like
actually I'm just the right amount yeah
then we have
tomorrow yeah tomorrow come on man
Kurama au courant oh sorry try the way I
did he news his Instagram this morning
so he's like there for like emotional
support and like I don't really get what
his job is but he's good at whatever job
it is do you know named Ian okay I'm
gonna disagree but you go through your
okay you go through then we have 10
friends who's everything and just puts
everyone in the same thing like a
short-sleeve and he's so college like
he's his Instagram he's always like
doing news with Gigi I did yeah yeah so
and also all these all these guys have
so many followers so like it's a chicken
and egg because did they get all the
followers from the show or they were
bigger at them all from the show so they
were like nobodies before the show
nobody is like Kamara Kurama was on an
MTV show I think he was em real world
he's a new host
Kurama wait like so the next season when
I turn che Oh second chances I forget
what oh that's okay never mind
whatever France who's like so sweet and
so supportive and like puts everyone in
the exact same outfit Antony who's
obviously only there because he's hot
because like no one really needs to
learn how to cook in order to get their
life together and like they literally
throw in him and his like grapefruit
salad as I could after thought of every
episode throwing grapefruit an avocado
and call this salad to a big man NASCAR
fan who like then they like not only
does he not need to be eating a salad
that's not a salad yeah
that's not that made me so angry and
then we have the most misunderstood
character of the entire show Bobby Burke
who does I don't think you know them all
by they first of all a bunch of them on
Instagram I only follow JVM he's never
on the show because he's so always
working renovating people's houses to
perfection like I feel like it's really
hard to design homes for men because a
furniture really is like so feminine and
especially if it's being designed by
like a gay man you don't know where it's
gonna go and he nails like that
masculine cool bachelor pad guide like
he's so good at a shop and he never gets
on the show because he's always busy
like renovating homes he does so much
work in a week he's amazing and Zach and
I watched it when we first moved into
our apartments we're like sitting on the
floor watching it like praying that
Bobby will show up and decorate her
apartment we
literally we're getting like design
ideas from the show I love Bobby
I need okay so my lease my favorite is
Jonathan yeah hands out of them
can you believe can you believe it
Beyonce yes goddess and then my least
favorite is Anthony me and by the way
we're alone in that everyone's obsessive
it's shocking to you I find him to be so
annoying the [ __ ] that he makes makes no
sense no saving and it's like trying to
relate cooking like analogies back to
like life analogies like it just not
work I stretch like yeah at least like
show them how to make like a real meat
like or who could have helpful tools
like how do you cut an onion or how do
you grill a piece of chicken like
helpful things not the great fruit
avocado salad was salad sorry using that
term very Mikado salad was so insane to
me and like that he thinks that that's
gonna fill up that man
I wasn't saying and his family is insane
and then her amo like I go back and
forth but because sometimes he just like
shows up like says something and it's
over it depends on the episode like he's
very episode very exotic yes
so some episodes he's great and like the
conversation is everything that we need
and everything that this world needs
right and then sometimes it's like
Jonathan could have had that
conversation with that guy about he was
cutting his hair right no like I'm of
the mindset like I really hate when like
entertainment things get political but I
think that the way queer I did it was so
important like they were going to
different parts of the country as five
gay men we're like literally some people
like they were the first gay people
everything's all in Georgia really yeah
bit like different part they were going
all over Georgia oh and then their loft
was in a pickup truck just like so oh my
god when they got pulled over by that
police officer I was freaking and I was
like how are they even showing this on
TV like put the cameras down I was shook
nope and then after even though it was a
joke like I was like I understood why
karma was like I'm not getting past this
yeah like oh my god I was I was so
scared
no I mean you know but I like loved it
also like it was like I was hilarious
i'ma get all the best friends like
sitting on the couch watching oh my god
I love that and I can't and also
jay-z and like posts about that guy that
comedian you know the guy who was living
in his parents basement and he's a
comedian he does stand
until they think oh yeah they got him
head chucking stuff like JB I'm was like
posting like our friend is like out
doing this show well cuz JV and also
does hand up because he yeah I just was
watching on his Instagram series but I
just think the way that they like it
wasn't even political it was almost like
educational yeah like go into different
parts of different country where like
they think that like people who go to
church like don't support the gay rights
and then vice versa they think that like
the the perception they haven't paid
people is that they're like crazy like
yeah so it's just nice to like have
people come together and just well
that's like we all agreed like do you
know what I mean yeah it was really like
bipartisan and I loved it loved also the
last episode with the firehouse was just
like so so [ __ ] sweet and he told
them how to make those hotdogs to sell
for $12 which was insane but the hotdogs
did look really good so I gave Antony
know and it's crazy American Bobby like
you know just going above and beyond
like what he did to that firehouse with
the huge fridges and the huge stoves I
get to feed a hundred people like and a
huge garbage can amazing and the fire
chief or whoever that guy was like
opting to do the firehouse instead of
his own home was just like so sweet and
also my favorite parts of the show is
when JB on like gets with the daughters
and they make like yeah I'm a face yeah
it's like that's real like those girls
can do that and they can help their dad
with his rosacea like oh my god no we're
teaching Tom how to use green stick like
that's what I use green can color doing
when my face is like really red in the
rosacea he had a he had like at some
inflammation yeah but I like my cement a
piece gets really got so under my
foundation I'll use like green color
corrector and that's just like such and
it really worked no and you never think
of like as a man like cutting their hair
can like make that big of a difference
cuz like all boys have the same hair but
like what John Ben did like a lot of the
guys was unbelievable especially Tom I
think also after Tom which was far and
away the best episode my second favorite
episode weirdly was that guy I think his
what name was Neil and he was like very
introverted he had a really long beard
of start and he was taught like he was
just like so he didn't write in his
mouth and he'd like to talk about how he
was like a little depressed before the
guys came like now he has this new lease
on life and like that's like
life-changing like you know changing
mind like straight guys are like so
unemotional like introverted and like
we're just bringing out like the best
parts of these guys and like it was such
a good show and like I'm so excited for
season 2 I'm so excited I wasn't in like
literally one day oh of course there's
no other way to do it I'm so glad we got
an opportunity to talk about it yeah I
forgot from Yankee drama to a director
regular anybody has a lot of money yeah
I'm sure he does okay now we're gonna go
to do your toasters which if you are new
to the show which hopefully you are
something's we're getting new listeners
new your toasters desired by segment we
do it every Wednesday but yesterday we
had very prestigious banette what I've
Nino on the show so we didn't want to
interrupt and rush through it basically
if you email dear toasters at gmail.com
you can get your advice read on air it's
all in on this so don't worry you can
use like surnames if you want but we're
talking about relationships we're
talking about parents we're talking
about pretty much anything under the
girlfriend's boyfriend's best friend
wedding stuff right it blings anything
you need advice so make sure to email to
your toast or such email comm so maybe
next week we will read your advice on
here today we're doing for because we
usually do three but we [ __ ] up and
did do yesterday so we're doing four and
apparently they're really good but I
haven't heard them yet because I want to
be surprised
okay I'm talking yeah we never I have
not read them either Jacob select to
them thank you very much okay first up
two months ago my mom passed away
unexpectedly my parents were divorced
and our family had our complicated
issues as I'm learning literally
everyone does but this has been by far
the hardest thing I've ever had to deal
with I love my dad and brothers but
being the youngest child and only girl
has made me feel like this loss is
different for me my friends have been so
supportive but I could tell that the
people who told me quote whatever you
need I'm here meant it however I'm only
20 so most my friends fortunately have
not lost a parent yet and cannot fully
understand nor do I want to bum them out
in the moments when the going gets tough
most of the time I'm doing okay but it
comes in waves that some days leave me
with a crippling pit I really want to be
able to pick myself up in a healthy way
so I can acknowledge it then move
forward when this happens I was
wondering if you guys had any tips or
tricks no that's really good and like I
feel like I've experienced grief like
major grief twice and I hate to say like
I'm getting really good at it and like I
really feel like I'm like know how to
bounce back and like nothing you want to
forget about the person but like
sometimes a like used to feel guilty
even like a lot of time and go by and
like I wouldn't think about the person
that I lost and I was like oh my god I'm
a terrible person you know but there's
something like normal without that like
when I think about like what might
what the person that I lost would want
they wouldn't be looking moping around
you know yeah and like that gives you
motivation it's like when you're feeling
down it's totally normal to feel down
but like when you're feeling down like
trying think of like okay like if my dad
or my mom it was her mom right if my mom
knew that I was like sad in Moby and I'm
missing out on a good time with my
friends right now like it's not really
what she would have wanted like let her
guilt you into getting back out there
and then it eventually it'll like start
to feel normal but also like talking to
other people who have experience like I
like can't talk to people who've like
never experienced grief like when Jax
was like it's the first time I've ever
lost someone I'm like you're 40 like you
know how lucky you are I'm like I think
I'm a major grief moment at the age of
12 and like and you're 40 and you don't
know like that was shocking yeah so like
I think the older you get any and it
hasn't happened it affects you more the
harder it is to like grapple with so
like I totally understand like not being
able to relate or talk to people who
have never liked how the worst thing
that ever happened to them is like
having a grandparent die like that's
just life and like totally it's
important to like talk to people who've
gone through similar things yeah also
also it's also important like your best
friend doesn't have to have gone through
similar things sometimes it's easier to
talk to someone that you don't know that
well cuz you're not like so just yeah
and you can just like totally say how
you're feeling like also you say that
it's only been two months like give
yourself a break just once it's like not
it's really that long of a time and
really time heals all wounds so just
like give it time process in the way
that you need to don't put pressure on
yourself to like get over it because
it's not something that you ever get
over it's just something that you live
with and it just becomes the new your
new normal so just give yourself time
try small things to like you know when
you're feeling down to make yourself
feel better but you don't have to get
over it like so immediately and
sometimes not like feeling like you
can't talk to your brothers or your dad
like it's actually really normal yeah so
seeking out a friend who might like or a
distant friend who might have gone
through something similar it could
actually be really helpful also I don't
want little people say like their
grandparents like aren't important I was
just saying you know let's say that okay
no because like obviously people are
close with their grandparents for like
using parents okay you didn't say sorry
unless like I'm so self-conscious and
like everyone is like obsessed with
their grandparents so like we haven't a
grandparents in like 30 years so like
I'm just like sorry yeah and you didn't
say that and
nothing to apologize for but anyways
we're always here if you ever need to
email one of us we're like honestly I
like have a special like attachment to
the toasters group but like in a
different way than a lot of like the
people who aren't like the hosts of the
show actually do and I know that a lot
of people have found like a lot of
helpful like not even just in making
friends but just like helpful like
camaraderie community vibes in the
morning toaster spacer group which is
like the best part of doing the show so
if you're not in it make sure you're in
it also like for example the toasters a
lot of them like come together to like
help each other through stuff and even
talking to a fellow toaster who might
have gone through something like this
that you don't know so maybe like we'll
start a ghost where it's like people can
just like like it and if you want to
connect with someone who's gone through
something similar it's just nice to talk
to people and you realize that you're
not alone everyone will have to go
through this it's unfortunately at some
point in their life and unfortunately
the time has come okay
next up I'm getting married in August in
my dad's girlfriend of seven months just
RSVP'd for my wedding my dad girlfriend
okay just RSVP for my wedding she
included the message in the RSVP that
quote we plan on bringing the four girls
along her daughters are 13 11 and 9 year
old twins they have zero manners and are
super touchy they drive me my sister and
my fiance crazy I have lots of little
cousins coming so I can't use the excuse
of adults only how do I apply lightly
tell her about her kids can't come damn
okay this is the thing with when it
comes to weddings but you could really
do whatever you want like and sorry by
the way that's so bold of someone what
did you say on the invitation
the ashtray family mr. and mrs. after
that what did you say because what you
say makes a difference um that's why you
have to be super specific so you don't
get yourself second that's fine but you
already are so it's like not helpful
advice but honestly just be straight up
and bow they don't tell her tell your
dad tell your dad so that's what I
wishes I'd say yeah put it on your dad
it's your day it's your big day
girlfriend of seven months her her
little her little tikes can scratch yeah
totally and like when it comes to
weddings like I will never this is your
one chance to be a selfish as you could
possibly be take it I didn't ever be
offended ever again like for not being
invited to someone's wedding or not
being given a plus-one like because
having done it it's virtually impossible
I don't care how big your wedding is
it's impossible to get ever and you want
in there and like sometimes
have to take you know the toll for every
backseat it's out and you could also
mention if you want like maybe if your
kids were a little better behaved right
would have scored an invite
no one also like there's already like
resentment look like a dad's new
girlfriend like don't like she's being
something your little monsters into this
such a Miranda right now from The Parent
Trap yeah Meredith Meredith like because
like you're already in a position well
you know not everyone's gonna like at
least I didn't want kids yeah but don't
like give everyone another reason hey
they're already coming into hating you
because like you're just a dad's new
girlfriend like that's just the Rolly
where you're playing like sorry and also
I guess some guests don't bring guests
right you're someone's plus-one you
don't get a plus-one right so put that
in your pipe and smoke it next up here's
the sitch a few months ago my best
friend told me that he had feelings me
I'm assuming feelings for me I felt like
there could maybe be something more
between us so I said [ __ ] it in Dovan
but he was way more into it than me he
was way more into me than I was into him
I mean he told me he loved me while we
were talking in a bathroom at a party
the dynamic changes pretty quickly he
was ready to be in a relationship and
settle down and I'm more of an
independent gal you know totally also
there was so much pressure from our
friend group for us to be together which
makes things 10 times harder last week I
was like [ __ ] this I'm not happy anymore
and I told him that I wanted to go back
to being friends
I just never for my best friend
impossible impossible he was really
upset and said he's going to need time
but he doesn't know if we could go back
to how it was before I understand that
but at the same time I'm not willing to
lose him as my best friend I feel like
the longer I stay away the harder will
be for us to go back to how it was what
the hell do I do give him space can risk
losing him all together a safe bucket
I'm around and I hope he sucks it up
even though I know it hurts him so
ladies tell me what to do this is so sad
because like this kid did nothing wrong
except like like someone and like girls
are still annoying sometimes it's like
all we want is for voice like guys no
man they like us we like don't like them
anymore but you can't control the fact
that you don't like him it's not your
fault and him like being so head over
heels like you never expected that so no
one is in the wrong here but like I
don't know it's like kind of mean to
like stick around and like shove it in
your face like imagine if someone did
that to you like showed up everywhere
like with your friends like when you're
just trying to get over them do you know
Nemean yeah I am not the right person
for this question because I don't have
any guy friends so I can't relate
whatsoever but I just feel like either
you love like you need this person as
your best friend in there for like the
best sort of relationships come out of
friendships and like you guys can be
real or like you don't give a [ __ ] about
having this person around like I just
don't see how it's in between we're like
you don't want to date him like you are
not interested in that way but you have
to have him as a friend in your life you
know it's difficult crazy no I think
that's fine and honestly now that I'm
thinking about it like don't give him
space cuz you will truly never see him
again but like and then once you guys
reconcile it'll be like a whole thing
it's a whole thing but that's the risk
that you took by ruining your friendship
and starting to be and so the risk
didn't pay off so make her feel bad no
but like every time two people who are
friends aren't like thinking about
dating it's like this situation just
could ruin our friendship are we
prepared for that you weren't prepared
but it ruined your friendship be so mean
to this girl I think she has so many
other friends you have a large group of
friends now it's gonna be a little
awkward maybe you guys can ease back
into things but for now things can't go
back to the way they were immediately
give it time like I said time heals all
wounds
wait harsh side but okay do you disagree
with me or it's just harsh it's harsh
and I kind of disagree with you because
like I have like one Iife at cuz I've
had one really good man friend my hand
and like it was definitely weird when
like ever
he really has a lot of girlfriends and
it's like difficult when everyone
started getting into relationships cuz
like how do you bounce girls and guys
like really can't be friends like I
think I've mastered it cuz I gave my
best friend but I don't know but I get
like wanting to have someone like who's
your best friend but not wanting to like
date them yeah but after having dated
them you didn't experience that part
right no no it wasn't everything like
should we date no no I was always like
you're gross I'm gross like yeah but I
don't know like I get wanting to like
not lose a friend
and like honestly just get over it like
both of you stop being such postseason
just like to be free I think you should
give him a little bit of time like maybe
he'll meet someone new and like realize
you did the right thing and hey let's
all be friends again yeah you just you
never know what's meant to be will be in
the words of bebe Rexha if it's meant to
be something if it's meant old on what
are we thinking about do you need a B
you know
I can't think of the words how does
reduce here and relax boy what is it why
don't you just sing the corner because I
want her part but you don't know it and
my heart's been hurt a couple times by a
couple of guys I didn't treat me right
I ain't gonna lie I ain't gonna lie
because I'm tired of that they love show
man watch your Maggie the girl made me
believe oh hold up another epic fail if
it's meant to be it'll be it'll be baby
if it's meant to be if it's meant to be
it'll be it'll be baby if it's meant to
be
so will you ride with me ride with me
see where this thing goes
I can get the best song of all time I
don't agree but I'm alive like you but
it's like it's a fine song it's like a
standard like put it you can make it
like cookie cutter country song cute
like it I know I said I didn't want to
eat these but I'm like they're just
staring up funny have the pie running of
the booty a little bit really crunchy a
little booty before noon there we go
you don't want to eat ready strawberry
what soon it's they're so delicious
[ __ ] disgusting these are for kids
right yeah and adults everyone could use
a food snack actually I didn't remind
that bad okay glad to hear it
last extra bonus toasters because we
didn't do it yesterday and we have just
such a muscle there's just so many
problems to discuss I just moved to a
new city and started a job a new job
post-grad everything started out great
it was a super small office with only a
few girls my boss explained to me on the
first day that we had ut-oh unlimited
time off and as we fou by I noticed my
boss and fellow co-workers we're taking
a lot of time off so I started to take
off take off days here and there and
hope like if you have an unlimited time
off like why wouldn't you just take off
every single day
well Ben technically has its own limited
time off but there's no limit days you
could take off like at one time II mean
no like so why don't I be like hey guys
I'm taking off 365 days I'll see you
next year yeah because the other thing
is that you're not supposed to abuse it
okay
yeah so bad unlimited you know it's
unlimited but it's like it's not like
you have only 14 days a year and you
have to plan your vacations around that
like you just have to be able to do your
job
fill your responsibilities and also be
able to go on vacation yeah also some
places like it's like you have 14 days
but they don't keep track of it it's
like an honor system so you know giving
you a little bit more leeway yeah
or like you're working from home I love
working from home okay my co-workers
were taking a lot of time off so I
started to hit off days here and there
my life got kind of crazy with family
loss and due to this I had to take off
time for funerals and emotional
decompressing in total I would say
probably a week and a half spread out
over over to out over time once I got
back my boss pulled me into office with
zero warning and flat-out fired me for
taking too much time off after she had
spent two weeks in Aspen I was
blindsided to say the least not only did
they never warned me but they were legit
excuses not like I was jetting off to
Cabo where as quickly sent home and
obviously in tears I email my boss
thinking her for everything and to get
any feedback on my work performance
since that matter was never discussed
all she said back was you were
terminated with cause I've also
contacted the girls other girls at the
company and no one will answer me I'm
truly just confusing want more
explanation especially if I'm going to
be putting up them as a reference in
future job pursuit so I straight up call
them or lead em alone and move on that
is so weird because like I need you to
if she got fired for taking off a week
and a half or but she's just like bad at
her job because that's possible too and
like maybe she's in denial but like why
no one will tell her it's like annoying
and frustrating but it's like I've never
gotten fired before actually that's not
true
but like I've never got my normal fire
like that wasn't written in bus right
wait I got to take your Baba when you're
playing how you kiss out so like I don't
know how that works but like when you
get fired like you get an explanation
for are you fired or you just get fired
um I think it depends it seems like this
is like a small illegitimate company
when it sounds fake as [ __ ] I like real
human resources but like real HR is like
supposed to tell you why you're fired a
budgetary concern and then push you out
the door right look like slightly shove
you yeah but a lot of times like with
bigger companies like it's really hard
to fire people you have to like have
like a million like yeah a million
reasons luckily we got that's what that
songs about yeah she got fired no I'm
just curious so like maybe like these
they don't want to hurt her feelings and
letting her know she was terrible at her
job yeah and also
regardless like you were working an
illegitimate company that everyone no
one was ever showing move on they did
you a favor by letting you go and you
should see that the only thing that's
frustrating is the referent reference
part you should 100% to put them down I
don't think anyone calls your references
that's not true
really that is not true I've never had a
reference call a reference okay I've
been called as a reference for who for
what who worked for you some fake like
internship
okay then they I know it's own it's like
such a hard worker I like never about
the girl you know so crazy I've never
had a reference be called out and I've
had a reference be called up for me but
that's so that's that you for that it's
fake because you've never had anyone
working but it was no it was when I
worked for someone oh no no it was for
my um my coop your coop my building is a
co-op so you had to put together package
with like references and I put like a
bunch of people and they called those
people oh well that's a bill that's if
I'm not someone who's like living with
you for like jobs and stuff I mean I'm
just saying personally I've had a few
jobs now and my references have never
been called before we wrap up this
episode I need to talk about real houses
in New York Oh first sure it was
obviously an amazing episode finally
finally I don't even remember what
happened because all I can think about
is Bethany in Miami with Jonah let's
just let's get into it because like
honestly cook and know like Bethany and
the before all this happened she said
you know we owe like Rare on Sonia for
talking about her old life and she's
really talked about her husband which is
true Chuck's out with the yacht and
traveling and all that stuff and God in
the up Jo shop yeah she never really
talks about her husband and like not
that it's even comparable but like
certain divorces are like deaths like
it's almost worse to like have to see it
the man you're obsessed with like start
a new life with someone not as it's
almost like it's it's really bad and
like when Bethenny said that she is that
Dorinda has a better chance of seeing
her husband again now so you know funny
but it's almost true lady's chair so
like I'm like compassionate for Sonja
and I think everyone really ganging up
on her is not nice and I think towels of
this Carol is like really like jumping
on the bandwagon where like Carol isn't
no reason to be mad at Sonja yeah but
she's like in the thick of it I don't
know because I'm kind of with Ramona
on this like Ramona love Sonia like that
when do you watch watch what happens
live the in memoriam ramonja the way
that they did that was so funny larious
but like Ramona is give is trying to
bring Sonia back into the fold and like
Sonia it's just like not on planet Earth
for some things like I think the Dorinda
Sonja conversation like I'm I don't
think that Sonja was totally in the
wrong and I think you're in it just like
what just because there was a death like
it's super seats everything and you're
never wrong about anything and that is
the way you feel when you're there
talking to someone who like who's
bringing up death yet I can't Trump
death sorry I'm out but I don't think
what Sonia did was wrong but once she's
like challenging like what Ramona's
trying to help her and she's not seeing
that like that's when I'm like she's
wrong but I don't really think I don't
see but Bethenny like getting Sonya all
these chances that's honestly
hypocritical remember when Sonya went
into her office and then saddest thing
ever drag raced her through the coals
about her cheater brand like because a
[ __ ] woman she was trying to money
that dollar after filing for chapter 11
like and she destroyed her house like
people want to use that like you're the
meanest I don't really see Ramona trying
to bring Sonya back into the fold I
think that like everyone's hating on
Sonia I'm like Ramona has a reason to
and Ramona's like very much like wants
to be like with the cool kids and it's
like even making her circumstances with
Sonya that much more dire because like
everyone else hate Sonya like I'll hate
on you too now I don't know I I don't
and I love LuAnn for sticking up for Lou
for Sonya and I just love like nothing
I've always loved Sonya like she's might
be my favorite house site but this
season there's something up first say
what's up she's saying she's on pills
like she's not lying right but it's
affecting like she's not having like
real relationships like it's weird I
don't even remember one thing Luanne did
in this episode was she even in it she
went to dinner with her daughter who
looks so different that's all I'll say
she went to dinner with her daughter and
it was really nice they were cute like
two girls how downtown's crazy they're
both like single in New York they should
live together no they totally should I
forgot all about her but what I did love
was Sonja like cleaning up her house
that's just it was really honestly funny
cuz like I've been looking for
apartments now and it's like funny how
like all these pictures lie and there's
the proof like those pictures were for
Chase right yes
and the require fireplace wasn't even on
like they lie so much and then the crop
out like stains ya know and there
showing the cow her house is falling
apart is so perfect but Ryan Serhant on
watch what happens live did say that
that should go for 30,000 yeah and he
also said that Bethenny's investment was
a good investment in the Hamptons I
think he doesn't want to piss her off
I completely agree and when he was
saying like would you do that Jeff ride
Chuck he was like they're perfect for
each other like ya know he's smart and I
think he sure was doing really well I
know I haven't seen it but people love
it and like Brava moved it to Tuesday
nights and like it's getting a lot of
prestige and I think a lot of people are
watching it does that mean that we need
to watch it no it's like it's too much
on me honestly and if I'm gonna watch a
show like that I'm watching tabatha
takes over yeah or watching career I
again okay what else happened on the
bouquet also my aunt about during the
Miami because if it had been anyone what
during the day that that dinner was
unforgivable unforgivable not only was
she just embarrassing period like by
being that drunk in front of like
colleagues she was sober Takei who
literally dedicated his whole hey four
years and he's like it's actually seven
and a half that was unforgivable
unforgivable and like what she was
saying the cause of it was like so
[ __ ] up like you know like you know
he's still not back on their feet like
let's just forget about them no and also
she was like they're gonna college
yeah oh right like a three years after
the hurricane they're not going to
college why not no no he's like no no
actually like I've seen them and they
are they are going to college like I'm
watching no it was it was so bad and was
hard no one else had first of all
Bethenny like that was so major Bethenny
to invite her and [ __ ] off [ __ ] over all
the other girls so who by the way Carol
was pissed stuck her neck out for
Dorinda and you're in and not only like
didn't rise to the challenge she [ __ ]
up majorly like that would eat crunch of
ending for me personally but do you
think I think that a lot of the girls
make excuses for Dorinda like I don't
know why I like this is like really
similar and we said this by the way but
he said this like three weeks ago that
like she says really low things and like
does really though things and people
like don't attribute it like to like
she's like the same level as Brandi
Glanville they were like Brandi said
c-word like she does similar vibes and
like no one cares and ever makes excuses
for her like why because I think like as
a woman she has a great head on her
shoulders like she is a great person I
don't think and these things only
happened like when she's drunk whereas
like Brandi like sober sober you start
slinging
mean words and like mean it is I really
this getting sandwiches if you're gonna
carry alone Here I am
excuses her during the gym no way I'm
amazed I are we all making excuses for
what Rinna shanon's memorization on the
plane like my I was just like I couldn't
moved like I was paralyzed I was felt so
terribly good everything that she said
yeah sometimes I wake up and I think
this is my life and like I'm gonna be
alone forever but also the same time she
literally has a boyfriend who just wants
to marry and move in with her and she
like won't let him so like I don't
understand right something you don't
want to be alone but that's what she
needs to figure out but like that
doesn't mean that you go insult a man
who's dedicated his whole life to
charity no no not even that I think she
was like speaking really derogatory
about John who like has only been nice
to her
yes I felt badly for John in the movie
too because and even in the in the
moment and all these shoot I mean in the
side interview she was like you know I
love John but but he's gonna see that
it's weird cuz when you think about
their relationship like it really it
feels like there's three people in it
like drainage on and the ghost of
Richard and he's so and like I feel like
when you're someone who date's a woman
or a man who like lost a partner like
you have to be really understanding like
I think Tiffany Thornton's new husband
is like really understanding about the
fact like they're so grieving and like
you still talk about the person and like
it takes a really understanding person
to like date someone like that and he
doesn't ever seem to be bothered when
she says oh my Richard husband was bald
like I love all men when they were at
that half dinner in the Hamptons and
like his face when Dorinda starts
talking about like the bald okay and
also that case it was like no but he
just like seeing like one please stop
and to like so like sad no he's like
he's pathetic and she like really like
wears the pants like I call it the shot
I can look they don't even live together
like yeah and if she wants to not live
alone and like hey I'm you found dead
with the smell let John find you let him
move in yeah I just think her situation
is weird and I just think that like
everyone really needs to stop making
excuses for like she's been and she
really like and I feel like it drinks
too much if once like she was punished
the way Ramona or Sonia are for what
they do when they're drunk like which
was being ostracized you know five
episodes of fighting and back in
furniture there's aa maked in the pool
in Mexico like she might learn from it
as opposed to being forgiven the next
morning without even having to say sorry
right so why why is that why does
everyone forgive her and I think
Bethenny is like onto it now how does
she not get hung over like I know that
my hangover is like every day that I get
older my hangovers are getting worse
like what I can't even imagine what my
hangovers will be like at hurry
I can't leave two arenas first instinct
was until I get on the plane and
apologize like maybe she didn't remember
I can't believe her first instinct
wasn't to not go because I were not
invited like why should the people of
Puerto Rico suffer because during does
an alcoholic but what it's like I don't
know that they're suffering like the
money's getting to them regardless yeah
but like you know what I mean yeah and
I'm really excited to see them in Puerto
Rico next week I am I got what she's
doing is incredible in Iran that's
what's so great like that what's so
impressive about what she's doing is the
logistics like the shipping the weight
the pound the warehouse how are we gonna
get like this cargo over to Puerto Rico
we need planes like boats
the logistics is what's so crazy because
the crowdfunding raising money is you
know it's pretty streamlined that's
right you just but it's like what you do
with that money like cash cards I don't
know what a cash card is and how you can
buy things at a store when the store
isn't up and running I don't know but
it's amazing and she's like injecting
this money into the Puerto Rican economy
that's what's so good about it
right no she's a genius and Carole was
so jealous when she heard that she
didn't know when they said time when
Ramona told her that to her when to
Puerto Rico like that was the first time
she heard about it and she was like
agreed with that mate and I'm really
excited to see their fight next week and
like I'm so Kate I can't believe what
Bethenny said she's like you just echo
people you echoed Heather you echoed me
and I didn't Carole I don't think of
like a follower because she is her own
person but I just think she likes like
have a best friend yeah
which in that sort of situation like
that's the best place you could be in
like with someone on your side like
you're never like left alone like Sonja
right and like with Heather and with
Bethenny like Heather and Bethenny were
both the stronger personality's more
loud but like her and Tinsley are pretty
much equal in terms of like they're both
like kind of quiet and shy if anything
they Tinsley kind of echoes her yeah so
I don't know I'm confused I'm really
excited with obviously I'm like of the
mindset now we're like I don't care
who's right or wrong like I'm team
Bethenny like all the way I think she's
just so smart I agree I trust her but I
think in the way that she handled this
situation with her in a yes but
sometimes she's like lash it's like if
that had been Ramona the lashing
I wish the lashing we would have seen no
like look I really hoped her in her
watch last night's episode and those
like take a moment to reflect I mean I'm
sure she's I'm sure that's like so
embarrassing embarrassing to watch also
I just want to talk about Tinsley and
how much I love
I know wait by the way she debuted a new
side commentary into interview look last
night which won the high pony where her
eyebrows are literally up to her hair
yeah her eyebrows are you know you used
to write what's up was a little carrot
there that they're terrible again I
didn't even I didn't not only I think
her hair was pulling them back she must
have like just gotten some Botox like
literally she's like this that's crazy I
love her dearly and I would you currents
got to be forever together forever and
start having meeting her lunch with
Carole like okay they did the thing I'm
macho up inside like just Kerala has she
ever been to a restaurant before should
I'll have three eggs over-easy
and she was like dividing up the eggs I
was like once again works you just got
three scrambled eggs like she's like I
didn't even know hard-boiled was an
option to that was crazy but I have to
say at the end of the day what you
ordered looked really good totally
didn't they would I put in watermelon
slices like it was so weird the whole
thing so but that restaurant actually
looks good
it's called Howard's I'm in them I need
some good new restaurant me too uh what
else what's the win up to we already
spoke about her and her daughter and we
did everyone we hit everyone ramona
showing up to the manicure with her
extensions being out of control and when
she was saying you know what's so
interesting she was like I just wear
workout clothes all the time because I
make work so late when she came on her
show she was like during that time cuz
they were filming she was wearing
workout clothes and she literally looked
just like that and she was like oh
always just running around town she was
epic
I love her I love her too I watch what
happens I last night she looks great she
looked thirty years old I can't believe
she's 60 what I need to go to her doctor
she also said that up the ten year she's
been in the show she doesn't have a say
no regret and I just would love to be as
big of liars her you know
well I guess because like some people
like live life no regrets because you
know you want to be where you are now
and for those things however you could
be some grieving better yeah [ __ ] you
guys it has been a true pleasure hanging
out with you this morning and this is
the morning trust we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube on Facebook and then
available the podcast app so make sure
you subscribe to our YouTube page give
this video a thumbs up the but also make
sure you like us on Facebook and you
leave a five star podcast review about
how amazing beautiful and gorgeous we
are I'm Claudia sure a girl with no job
I'm trying going oh sorry sorry I'm
going on tour sort of I just like to say
that I still have tickets available for
my show in Nashville June fit
I would love to see you all there I'm
Takeo Takeo problems I'm going home to
our river bye